may i start first of all by extending my
heartfelt condolences to you both for
the most traumatic loss of your daughter
she seems like the sort of person
i would have liked to know so thank you
so much for talking to us
about all of this given the nature of
of kim's death and the interest the
press interest from around the world and
and the interest in the story what made
you agree
to do the investigation we did that
because
we get a great confidence in tobias
lindholm the
director and the author of the series
and we see this as a big thank you to
all the
men and women that did the outmost that
we could have
the entire came back home to bury her
and it's it's a great honor to to all
these people all these uniformed people
who
done their a great great job it's
interesting you're keen throughout the
investigation series it's a six part
series isn't it you
you really get a sense that the
background that you and your wife share
and indeed kim shed
of journalism really is interweaved with
the way
the the portrayal of the investigation
this kind of search for truth the search
for
facts the the integrity uh is that
behind perhaps the sort of
unlikely friendship that you formed with
yen smaller the lead investigator
it could be the start of it because
i refused to leave out the
kim's computer to the police in denmark
because
as a journalist myself and a
photographer i know
to protect my sources and kim was
very kind of that
too that's
fascinating and you know what was the
basis then do you think
for um collaborating so closely
with jens muller i know that there were
times when you even
recommended the path that the police
should take i think it was your
suggestion wasn't it that
the police should use dogs in the
underwater search
it was a long time and we had many many
telephone calls together
and it was a trust
a mutual trust between us that we
we trusted each other and he always
called us before he had a press
conference or something like that
and told us that he will tell the press
this and this kind of message
but we are not talking about this and
so we we didn't talk about it and he
he get more trust in us and we it grows
up
and with the dogs that
we he we had a telephone call
and he was quite sad but and worried
about the divers
they are nearby giving up because they
couldn't find anything or
kim's remain on the bottom of this large
bay where they were seeking and i asked
him if
they couldn't if they have tried
to use special trained dogs
which we have in sweden but he said
we don't have that in denmark and i
asked him if
he or i should call for the swedish
police dogs
and he did it and i did it too
and of course that proved absolutely
pivotal in the investigation didn't it
ingrid tell us a little bit about your
note making because again your
journalistic background
soon after kim went missing you decided
to to make a note each day of the phone
calls that you received the people that
you'd spoken to the support you'd got
and that eventually became a sort of
diary and i i wonder was that used by
the producers
uh in in the creation of the
investigation i think it's a
journalistic habit to
take notes on on everything and i've
been working as a journalist for my
my entire working life so uh and
so for the beginning it was just for for
myself but
then i understand that this could be a
book
maybe just a book for for for us the the
closest
friends and family but uh it became a
book
it's in english called the kimball the
silenced voice
and of course tobias
he has written the book but i think that
what's in the in the tv it's it's the
result of
many long talks with with us
and and to us and just
explain to people watching this
interview and who have watched the
series that's been on bbc2 here in the
uk
explain to people how you've been able
to to find the good
in this situation to focus on on on the
good work as you say the painstaking
work of the copenhagen police homicide
department
what motivated you to to be able to do
that
we have to do it otherwise we have
fallen down in this big black pit and
never gone back to life again so for us
and we have to live on so for us this
was
the only way that we could survive it
was to make something good
out of it and we think that the the tv
series
focused on not focus on kim but
she as a journalist take part in in the
tv series
and of course we work also with the
kimwild memorial fund
and that's also give us some meaning
that
it comes something good out of this
terrible
tragedy and tell me more about the
kimval memorial fund what what is it
aiming to achieve it's for young female
journalists
who want to go out in the world and make
make stories in kim's spirit and now
that kim can't go abroad and make those
stories anymore
it gives us the meaning that we can send
out others
and right now we are in the middle of
finding this
year's grantees and we have so many good
applications so
we know that for many many years to come
we will be
able to to send out young female
journalists from
all over the world to go out and make
stories in kim's
spirit and just tell us a little bit
about what viewers would have seen it in
the last episode
of the investigation last night when you
were standing in front of a room
of young journalists what what was your
message to them
it's not young journalist it's pupils on
the
on the local uh high school and we've
did that
several times and because we think it's
so important that we tell young people
to to do what kim did
go out in the world make a difference
even if you come from a small town like
12 boy in sweden
you can go out and have the the entire
world as you
as your working field and we would like
him to be a role model for
for young young people and we will
continue that
so long that anyone will listen to us
so we will tell what kim was and what
she stood for that's
our main goal and
kim was an amazing journalist an amazing
girl just give us a sense of the sort of
person she was
she was extremely stubborn
and she was very determined and if she
had set her
mind on something then she she did it
even it was steep hill
many many times so she she tried to
to achieve what she had set in her mind
and
it not always succeeded but she tried to
do her best and
we think that in the 30 years that she
she lived
she achieved a lot and she traveled all
over the world and so
yeah and of course you miss her dearly
how hard is it for you to be involved in
things like the investigation
in indeed doing interviews like this
yeah i think that's uh that gives us a
meaning to
to tell the world who kim was not and
let her be remembered not as as a crime
victim but for for the for the daughter
fiance sister journalist friend
that that she was that's the most
important for for
us to she she was a talented brilliant
young woman and we will her to be
remembered like that
well i'm sure she'd be so pleased only
this thing
that she was a mother language
in swedish went out of columbia school
in new york with almost on the
journalist
uh education and with a master degree
that's incredible yeah
go on ingrid sorry we are incredibly
proud of her
and we will be there that for the rest
of our lives